what up guys welcome to the just curly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sit down where I bring on content
creators from all different walks of
life to talk about political and social
commentary today I'm so excited I'm like
this is the most excited I've ever been
we have Scott Adams here for an
interview and this is especially
exciting for me because I used to watch
you every day in a normal way like
online
that's good to know I never know who's
watching me or or how but I'm glad it's
the good way
commentary you you are an author as well
I just bought your book so for how did
you get into this space like originally
you did Comics right well it started
with yeah Dilbert comics but I always
saw myself as more of an entrepreneur
than a artist and so my background is I
have an MBA degree in economics a lot of
business experience before I did
cartooning so cartooning was just one of
the things I tried and of lots of
different things so I never really
stopped trying stuff so at one point
um I had a young stepson
ooh I thought wouldn't it be good if I
had some way to you know transfer all of
my knowledge you know the things that it
took me years to learn what if what if
he got them early you know what what an
advantage that would be so I wrote my
book kind of failed almost everything
and still went big and that was big yet
um that's probably the most influential
book in the uh personal success category
a lot of other books use the ideas
systems better than goals and talent
Stacks that sort of thing and it did so
well that uh my publisher said you got
any more books in you and I wrote one
about persuasion and my latest one is
reframe your brain it's had actually
tuned your brain
um I'm a I'm a hypnotist by training as
well so when in my 20s I learned to be a
hypnotist and so uh I'm kind of always
living in that world of reframes you
know what's what's set of words can you
put it on something to change how people
act and feel about it so I put together
all the best ones and they're the ones
that will change your life reframe your
brain can you explain the reframe part
yeah so reframe is just a simple
sentence that makes you think about a
familiar thing in a different way that
makes you break through or you know
makes you happy or more successful so
I'll give you some examples
um the what the first one was kind of
accidental I told people that I often
tell myself that alcohol is poison and
it's because I was trying to cut down on
my casual you know weekend drinking sort
of thing and it completely stopped it
and then when I mentioned that uh in
public other people eventually got back
to me and said hey I quit drinking too
because I heard you say alcohol is
poison and I thought really it can't be
that easy
we're not talking about Alcoholics we're
just talking about people who wanted to
you know and I have alcohol in their
life and that I'd heard from more people
and I just kept hearing from people and
they would say the same thing that one
sentence changed my life alcohol is
poison now the reason that works is that
our brains are not just rational uh
machines cartoonists are not hypnotists
learn that people are irrational 90 of
the time and only once in a while are we
rational when things don't matter you
know when the stakes are low we can be
rational but mostly we're irreshed and
then we rationalize it after the fact so
once you realize that then you can build
reframes that are themselves irrational
but so is your brain so if you put this
little irrational code into your head it
can sometimes optimize it so the
irrational part about alcohol is poison
is that it's not really but it sort of
is so your brain kind of accepts it even
knowing that you could easily call it a
beverage but the trick here is that our
brains are like uh the same way that AI
works so AI works by looking at the the
arrangement of words that have ever been
spoken or written and then just
predicting what happens next in a given
situation based on word patterns so word
patterns alone Ray is something called
intelligence or something we recognize
as intelligence so you can do the same
thing with your own brain you can just
change the word patterns that are in
your head and that in turn changes
effectively changes your intelligence
and that changes what you do so simply
pairing alcohol with poison is
irrational but your brain says ooh
poison run away yeah if you if you
paired alcohol with beverage
or entertainment your brain would say
ooh beverage I'm thirsty or ooh
entertainment that's always good so it's
simply just pairing the word with a
negative was enough now that was the one
that sort of got me going but I came up
with a 160 and everything from success
to your personal life wait so how do I
quit show I have to be like sugars
poison I've been trying to do that for
years like rather unsuccessfully well
well you're you're more uh on point than
you could imagine there because there
actually is a book called and sugar is
poison now I learned about it after
after I did the alcohol reframe I found
that some years ago somebody had created
basically the same trick but with sugar
now I don't need sugar but
um or not not enough to quit so I
haven't used that one
um but I have other reframes that would
help you quit sugar a different way like
what well my biggest reframe for a diet
is that you don't want to challenge
yourself in every way all at once
because we're we're a little too weak
for that so you don't want to deny your
favorite tastes at the same time you're
denying the quantity that would fill you
up those are two different urges
sometimes you just want the taste
sometimes you're just hungry
so what I do is say break those up and
only work on the taste and only work on
one item at a time for example I had a
terrible problem eating these giant
Snickers bars sometimes three a day
just the worst thing you can do it's
kind of slipped into it because I like
one and then I think well I had one but
it was so much earlier today I could
have another and then later I'm just
hungry I want the taste so I found that
if I just get rid of one thing allow
myself to eat as much as I want of
everything else I eventually lose the
craving and then it's easy so it takes
about two months to lose a craving and
then I just pick the next thing go okay
my next thing is I ate too much bread
I'll eat as much as I want if anything
else so I'll never be hungry but I just
won't eat bread and then I'm not even
thinking about snickers because I've
already removed the Cravings so one at a
time and you never have anything like
suffering every day eat as much as you
want of good food things that taste good
and eventually you get to the point
where sugar just doesn't feel like
something you'd want to put into your
body
and I did the same thing with Diet Coke
probably I don't know 20 years of
drinking maybe 12 Diet Cokes a day oh my
gosh my dad does the same
thing he does the same thing I
eventually when cold turkey but I can
only do it because it was the only thing
I was removing from my life so I could
get my dopamine and everything else
other way is and then eventually about
two months it turned into from the most
delicious addictive substance I've ever
had the pleasure of enjoying to why
would I put like a weird little chemical
in my body my brain just did that on its
own so now when I look at Diet Coke I
think why why
why would I want to put chemicals in my
body I don't even know this doesn't make
sense so the urges go out and then your
brain just reprograms and sees it the
way it should have been seen you also
taught me Talent stacking I I did I
actually didn't remember where I got
that from until you said it right that's
like you you said that was what Trump
did right yeah well a lot of people who
are successful so Talent stacking uh
that was my first book how to filled
almost everything and still went big but
I included it and reframed your brain
because it was the one that one of the
two that people picked out and said this
changed my life everything's different I
got two promotions because it it's the
idea that when I was a kid my mother
would say make it whatever you do you
can do anything you want or whatever you
do make sure you're the best at it you
know that's how you succeed you got to
be the best at that thing you're doing
but later I realized that what worked
better is just being pretty good at a
bunch of things that work well together
so my career is a perfect example
um I'm not a good artist but I'm good
enough that I can draw a picture and you
know what's happening I'm not the
funniest person even in a room if I if I
throw a party I'm not even the funniest
person in the room of people I I invited
so I'm not the funniest I don't draw the
best but it's very rare to find people
who can draw a little bit and are also
funny and then on top of that I have
business experience so I had a domain
that I could always pick from that you
know people would recognize
so you add those things together plus my
business experience which I think
probably was half of My Success knowing
how to navigate cartooning as a business
because really I think Dilbert is the
biggest comic in 35 years maybe you know
since the 8A of comics the biggest comic
has gotten smaller you know penis was
gigantic Garfield almost as big but uh
so it really was a combination of just
being pretty good at a bunch of things
that really fit together they gave you
the idea for the talent stack that you
start with whatever you're naturally
good at and you'd like to do for the
rest of your life and you say well what
can I add to that well what if what if I
learned to be a speaker
well then I could be the boss what if I
learned to be a speaker but I also
learned the the engineering and
technology and lighting to be a
podcaster oh now you're a podcaster so
every time you add a skill the number of
opportunities doesn't just increase by
one it probably increases by some
multiple and that's worked really well
for a lot of people you mentioned Trump
he's obviously somebody with a whole
bunch of different skills from
persuasion to business to politics uh
you name it he's just got a bunch of
things that work really well together
well because you were one of the wants
to predict that
that he right yeah 2015.
yeah I was I I think
Ian Coulter was there early for
different reasons I think she just
thought he was going to be right on
immigration and that that would that
would sort of put him over the top and
she she was largely right about that but
what I saw was he had a a stack of
persuasion talents that people who don't
study the field wouldn't recognize for
example he's always making you think in
visual terms he uses fear a lot fear is
the number one Persuader you have to you
have to you know save yourself before
you can even think of anything else so
he tells you that there's you know
criminals coming across the border and
China's going to eat your lunch and
there's all kinds of things to be afraid
of but then he also does the visual
stuff like we're gonna build a wall it's
gonna be a big beautiful wall with a
with a door and then then he also does
my favorite thing he does is he makes
you think past the sale a classic
salesperson technique so he doesn't just
say I want to build a wall because that
would make you think about the decision
to build a wall he says I'm going to
build a big beautiful wall it's going to
have a door in it so already you're
thinking past the building the wall to
how do you build it and then he says
Mexico is going to pay for it and your
head explodes and you're like what I
don't think you can get Mexico to pay
for it but if that's what you're talking
about
you've also you've uncritically accepted
the possibility that there will be a
wall that needs to be paid for and he
does this again and again and again and
then you you add to it his his genius
with nicknames you know oh he's so good
at it yeah low energy jab just took Jeb
completely out of politics with with one
deck babe that was all it took yeah and
then crooked Hillary too crooked Hillary
is another example of why he's so good
at it he picks things that maybe you
were already thinking or at the very
least the future news would confirm this
is actually his best trick he gives a
nickname that he can be confident the
future will create situations that fit
the nickname
so when he said that Hillary was crooked
in the context of a national election
you know both sides are going to accuse
each other of being Crooks like that's
just sort of basic so you knew she would
be accused of things that fit the fit
the nickname which would make the
nickname stickier which would make the
accusations stickier it's just it's just
genius to have a nickname that is going
to get stronger by events you know will
happen in the future and then low energy
gem was the same thing uh what I what I
would see Jeb I would think wow there's
a cool executive he doesn't get to you
know hot about anything he just he just
as you know a good consistent kind of
personality but the moment you heard he
was low energy
the moment you heard it he's done he
never saw him again he was he just
didn't have the energy to you know walk
across the room after that that's the
only way you can see it and the day I
heard it I said in public that's the end
you'll never see jab again he's done and
he was it was the end of it well that's
what I elect about because it's funny
you probably get s to when you become
like a
as much because you're gonna want
talking about it you know but but back
when um because I remember I listened to
you a lot
um I think it was either before or after
the Trump election I was like working in
copier sales I hated my life every day
I'd put you on on my way to work and
what I loved about you is you were very
like unemotional with it and you were
very much just like analyzing their
strategies and you had such like a sales
background I just thought it was such an
interesting I'd never heard it before
yeah well I don't have a sales backroom
background per se what happens
persuasion background yeah but sales
would be a subset of persuasion yes how
did you find working as a hypnotist did
you
I believe in
and they're on the stages because I had
someone try to hypnotize me once and
they sent me off the stage because I
like wouldn't do anything you know what
I mean well they said you're at the
stage well stage hypnosis is very
different from one-on-one
so stage hypnosis is part of magic trick
and part actual hypnosis and the the
magic trick part of it is that the
audience imagines it could have happened
to them as they're watching the people
who are on stage and the truth is it
couldn't so most people are like you so
80 of the public cannot have the Deep
hypnotic experience of you know feeling
things that are not there seeing things
that are not there uh so the hypnotist
on the stage is first trying to figure
out who are the most hypnotizable they
can usually do that before they even
call you up so they'll do something like
a classic one is put your hands together
now imagine you can't pull them apart
now they're really stuck together now
try to pull them apart now try and he'll
watch the audience most of the people
will just go
their heads will come apart like what I
I don't even know why that would have
worked like they don't even have any
concept of why that would have made any
difference at all but a few people and
maybe only five people have a hundred
are going to have something more like
this
it'll hesitate before it comes apart the
hypnotist focuses on them it's all right
all right you you you come up here and
then we'll try a further a further
suggestion to see if he chose correctly
so you must have had to tell or maybe
you volunteered in the audience
yeah I was like I want to go
well
uh that I would say maybe there was
something wrong with this act because if
he took volunteers he wasn't doing it
right
he should have started with people he's
pre-selected right that had a sort of
tell for hypnosis but to ask you a
question hypnosis is very real it's just
that different people can have different
outcomes so the 100 of people can be
hypnotized because 100 of people can be
influenced by marketing uh a better
salesperson can sell to them they can be
persuaded in a variety of ways and so if
you're just trying to persuade somebody
to be let's say less afraid of flying
that would work on almost everybody but
some people would give faster results
than others oh
are women more easily hypnosis
you could say it it's all right no the
answer is no the answer is no are you
sure yeah there's no difference by
gender
um you know ethnicity
uh intelligence people often think oh
the smart people can't be hypnotized
it's closer to the opposite not
confident smart people
that will buy into it and and they'll
basically say all right do what you will
because I feel confident you know like
I'm Not Afraid those people tend to be
easy because they're not resisting uh
somebody who's afraid of it would be
hard to hypnotize because they think oh
you're going to take over my mind at any
minute I'll become a puppet it doesn't
work I was thinking that a little yeah
people to do things that they wouldn't
normally do because they're still awake
they're still aware and they still have
full control the the way I describe
being hypnotized is like um
it's like
taking a driver's lesson so the driver's
coach is you know sitting in the
passenger seat and the the driver
instructor is saying you know do this do
this and you're doing it because the
instructor says so but you have the full
ability to take a left turn that the
instructor doesn't want you to take so
you have all of all of your abilities
you're just choosing to listen to the
other voice but you know you're doing it
while you're doing it now the reason
that people do it is that they're
achieving something they want to achieve
so if you want to be more relaxed in a
certain situation let's say not get
nervous during a tennis match you want
that and there's no part of you that
doesn't want it so you'll you'll go
along with the process you'll visualize
it until you're not nervous setting the
the ones that don't work is where people
really don't want the change fully
so somebody wants to lose weight will
come in and say hey can you hypnotize me
to lose weight
and I'll say something like are you
willing to stop eating no that's what I
want you to make me do I want you to
make me willing to stop eating that
doesn't work
I was hoping we could yeah I can't make
you want something you don't want but if
you do want it I can help you get it
right so what's your if someone okay
let's say someone is an absolute loser
like a fat broke loser what what's your
why we gotta start somewhere right which
I mean statistically I mean like 70 of
Americans are fat so it wouldn't even be
you know
so like what would be your advice to
like where they would start to reframe
their brain well you know Jordan
Peterson famously says if you don't know
where to start clean your room
and if you don't understand the the
reasoning behind that it sounds too
simplistic but I I have a version of
that which is do something
right the the universe rewards action
and it rewards it directly by making you
feel good when you complete the action
that's your little dopamine head but it
just makes you feel good like you're
you're heading somewhere like you've got
some vision of where you're going so
those two things are important but I
would tell somebody to work on their
Fitness First
I would say all right what can you
control
well you can totally control do you go
to the gym you can totally control you
know your uh options about food and by
the way one of my reframes is that uh
you should reframe diet away from
self-control
because and yeah that doesn't really
exist it's sort of an illusion and
toward knowledge the more you know about
diet and how things work the easier it
is to lose weight
so uh that's that's a useful reframe I
found that the people who know the most
about the food they're eating uh way the
least it's very it's very observable you
go to you can go to dinner with eight
people and look what they ordered and
look at their plates and without looking
at them I could tell you their weights
like I can just look at their food and
say well if that's what you thought was
the food that sustained you you're going
to be 40 pounds overweight there's just
no way around it and I look at the food
next to me and I go okay if that's how
you eat you're going to be right on
point probably for your whole life
so it's about knowledge more than
willpower willpower sort of imaginary
things what was the question oh what do
I do to get something going I first get
them to control all the controllables
fitness and exercise then I'd probably
get them to try to build a talent stack
and to build a talent stack they would
need to have a system as opposed to a
goal now a system is something you do
every day and it's leading you toward a
variety of outcomes not just one
specific one if you had a goal you're
going at one specific goal but a system
makes you better at all things so being
uh more fit
makes you better at relationships better
at getting jobs because we're all
influenced by the same stuff uh so it's
it's a system because it's not a
specific outcome of a job or dating a
person it just gives you access to all
of it
so develop a systems that give you the
most options make sure one of those
systems involves building skills that
are compatible that work well together
and that control everything that can be
controlled you know how many people you
meet what toxic people are in your life
uh your Fitness your your diet that's
where I'd start what do you mean
self-control doesn't exist Free Will
doesn't exist it's an illusion so this
is something hypnotists learned this
early
that the things we think are our
conscious choices are actually activated
that part of the brain doesn't even
activate until the choice is made and
science has been proving this for
decades every time they look for it
they're looking for a free will and they
can't find it because there's no part of
the brain that is free from the rules of
physics so the fast way to say it for
the Nerds is that the rule of physics do
not stop at your skull
everything outside your skull is purely
by the laws of physics if I drop the pen
it doesn't have an option of going up
every every particle in your brain all
the chemistry in your brain the
structure of your brain it can't do two
different things in one specific
situation every situation although we
can't uh predict it because there's too
much complexity but your brain doesn't
have the option of sometimes doing
something else it's going to do exactly
the same thing every time it's in that
exact situation
so there's no real free will there's no
room for it can I have an example an
example would be anything so you decide
uh to drive to the store
your brain could have only made that
decision it did it didn't have the
option of doing anything else you have
the feeling you have the option and you
have the feeling that you could have
decided differently but those feelings
come after the fact you were you were
going to go to the store like okay
because I was an athlete I played
and
um you could see really clearly over
time in sports like the chicks that
worked harder and chicks that didn't
because they would just start to suck
you know but so how to sell because I
would think like the chicks don't have
the self-controlled like lift or go to
practice or like how is it not you know
no all that stuff is labels you put on
it after the fact
so if you drop me into any situation you
know just drop me on an island I would
try to own the island because it's just
baked into my personality I would try to
be in control of the island if I could
okay now if you drop somebody else on
the island they might be lazy and they'd
say well I'll just eat berries and get
by
so it might look like a choice
I chose to conquer the island and
someone else chose to eat berries and
sit on the beach
but we are who we are I couldn't choose
the other thing
I mean I could in the common way we use
language I could I could walk over there
and eat a berry and sit on the beach but
my personality isn't that so I couldn't
I didn't have that option oh so you're
saying like people have certain
personality traits and therefore they're
just gonna make a choice based on their
personality yeah and I'm going even
deeper than personality trait I'm saying
that the actual physical structure of
your brain the actual folds of your
brain and the way the neurons are
associated there's only one way
right so you have a certain set of
experiences which are now part of your
brain structure because all your
experiences physically change your brain
but once it's physically changed that's
what you're working with it it doesn't
get to be a lawnmower here's a better
way to say it okay
if you think of your brain as just a
moist machine basically uh it's easier
to imagine a lawnmower
if if the lawnmower is perfectly
functional and it has gas in it and you
start it does it have the option of not
turning on
the answer is no
but you don't either your brain is going
to do what it does because of the
condition it's in and then whatever you
know inputs hit it from that point on
but then is it what
control be like
conditions
controls imaginary
you were you were going to do what you
were going to do
I should have said that to my dad when I
totaled my car at 16 dad I was gonna do
what I was gonna do you know
well you know the the problem is that if
we treated reality the way it should be
treated which is that we don't have
choice you would have to get rid of the
entire uh you know Department of Justice
because we'd say well he robbed the
store about what choice did he have
and then somebody else would rob a store
because that would create a new set of
physical incentives that would make
people who would not have ordinarily
robbed the store rob a store
so we have to pretend that people have
free will
so that we have a system that works
if if we were realistic and said you
know there's nothing you can do about it
people are people then there would be
chaos and everything would fall apart so
instead we we pretend that people can
resist but the only reason they resist
is we scare them into you know not
making those choices by fear really
you'll go to jail jail if you do this
okay so you're saying we should make
policies with like the idea that people
don't have self-control that we I'm
saying that the way we do it is
irrational the only an irrational
solution will work
you know in the same way that alcohol is
poison is not rational but it works
if we say you have to you know obey the
law and if you don't we're going to put
you in jail that does reduce the number
of people who break laws
but the person who didn't have a choice
is sort of the
you know the one who pays the cost for
that order because they were going to do
what they were going to do now I I have
a stepson
who
there wasn't any amount of uh let's say
coaching or or parenting that would
change anything he did ever and that's
one of those things where you could
really see it clearly like even when he
would agree
that one set of you know behaviors would
be better for him
even for him he wouldn't do that either
so there's some people's personalities
that are just so hard-coded uh it's a
little bit more obvious that they don't
have free will but uh it applies to the
rest of us we have no more or less Free
Will than than that example okay I kind
of get it but only sorted
all right
um okay so but would that go back to
like because I talk a lot about like the
divorce incentives in society so would
you argue that that they don't have free
will it's just like because they're paid
to leave well you know I used to say
follow the money
and that would explain everything but
I've just recently updated that to
follow the dopamine and that allows that
money is just a way to store dopamine so
if I have money in the bank and I need
some dopamine I can take some money out
and buy some jet skis and then go get
some dopamine on my jet ski or something
else so that's the way I say the world I
say the world as incentives and most of
those incentives are dopamine or
something that can get you dopamine like
money so if you look at the way we're
currently arranged versus the way we
used to be marriage was a full economic
solution so you get your kids who could
work on the farm maybe protect you
against Invaders you got a daughter
maybe she's worth something to get a
dowry depending on where you're living
um you know the woman would have
children you needed that the man would
do some heavier lifting and you needed
that and then they would have this unit
that worked together and kept them all
alive and that was that was good for
survival dopamine and money so I had
everything
but if you fast forward to where women
can earn as much as men
they could buy somebody to take care of
their kid
if they divorce somebody who is
successful they can take a bunch of
money and look for a better guy
so we now have created a set of
incentives that largely guarantees the
end of marriage except for maybe 25
percent of the public who can have the
Perfect Mate in the perfect situation
but largely it's not something that
could be fixed
you know with tweaking we have
guaranteed by Design the end of marriage
when I'd say the end they'll still be 25
who find it perfectly acceptable yeah
and then they'll be like
have you noticed that uh there's
something that the relationship experts
on Instagram have in common I was gonna
I was gonna bring this up today your
Tweet
yeah one of the things that all the
Instagram uh experts have in common is
that they are individually very
attractive
that that seems to be so you'll see the
guy he's often a guy and he'll say you
know you you can't treat can't give the
women everything they want you've got to
be tough you got to be Alpha and I'm
thinking that I'm listening and I'm
thinking and you have to look like you
because if if you if you treat somebody
poorly and you don't look like you
well good luck with that because you
know looking like you is 80 of why
anybody would stay with you uh you know
unfortunately we're just visual
creatures and shallow but I think your
reference to the Tweet was
the two things I've learned from uh
relationship experts on Instagram is
that if a man let's say I had a real man
gives a woman everything she wants she
will come to think of him as a simp and
a pushover and she will lose her
attraction to him then probably cheat so
you so the experts will tell you don't
give women everything they want now if
you go the other way
and you you give them nothing that they
want like you're tough about it uh they
will go find somebody who does give them
what they want because they imagine that
that person exists and you're with a
meaning and then people say Scott Scott
you're so silly you're taking two
extremes you're gonna have to find the
midpoint of those two things of course
you don't give the woman everything she
wants but of course you don't withhold
Everything She Wants You gotta find that
midpoint so I say all right let's say
you even do better than the midpoint and
you give the woman 75 of what she wants
what would her rational decision be at
that point
well if it's me I go look for somebody
who'll give me a hundred percent because
I think I deserve it and why is this guy
holding out my 25 sure I take for
granted the 75 I figure I could get that
anywhere but I want that 25 that's
that's the stuff I really needed
so
I'm not aware of any system that would
work the the only systems I've seen work
for relationships had some really
specific elements to them
they met really young
so they didn't have the disadvantage of
seeing you know what else is out there
they had both really good economic
um opportunities and jobs
so both of them could earn and be you
know full full members of the house and
they could make enough money to have you
know private schools and nannies and
stuff like that and in those cases those
look like really really strong marriages
the ones I've seen are just tremendous
but the people who wait to 30 and
they've got a lot of body count and
maybe they've been divorced once and
they have a set of requirements that
nobody can meet
so you can predict how that goes yeah I
have the same saying like women always
whine like we I don't know what it is
about us we just love to complain
so here's my theory
my theory is that the way we evolved uh
if if we evolved at all is that men are
designed to go out and get resources you
know food and protection and stuff like
that and women are designed to transfer
those resources through themselves into
the child
and that that's our basic operating
system
so under those conditions the woman
should evolve to have strategies to get
as much as possible from the man
and and they don't have the ability of
force I can't force him
so the only things you can use are your
emotions because Mountain can't stand
being in a house with an unhappy woman
so we will do anything to make the
whining stop
and here's the thing that no man
understands we we fall for this a
billion times in a row including me and
I will even fall for it tomorrow like
like I I will fall for this like I'd
never heard my own advice right
they never get what they want
there's no there's no such thing as as
addressing their needs and then you're
like well I guess I've got a few weeks
off because I've addressed all the needs
solved all the problems things are going
to be pretty good after this I mean Tom
Tom Brady got divorced you know what I
mean like well more like you got
America's like favorite footballer uh a
tall jacked handsome like what what else
Christian I've never even heard of them
cheating like I'm like
I I think his wife complained because he
was traveling too much for work
broke guys on my show she can go date
them they have free time it's like
they're not going anywhere
it's like well I started looking into
this into the history of like the
suffragettes and like feminism and you
know I realized like you know they all
warned that if women voted like we would
just spend too much money and just like
break up the family no I swear everyone
thinks I'm kid when I say that women
shouldn't vote I mean it I mean it to my
soul they're like oh she's just trolling
I'm like not at all like I'm 100 because
because I started reading the
anti-suffragettes writings and they're
like this is going to be the breakdown
of the family they're they're just gonna
spend too much money look at how much
they these were wives and mothers that
said this so I'm like I'm like
yeah you know I don't know what it is
about us it's like we like the feminists
you know that's like a woman's movement
they're still whining it's like that we
get paid so much you know wine but don't
women and men vote about the same no not
single women single women so this is
just doing the divorce documentary I
started like interviewing politicians
um and like people that have like
because I wanted to know why are these
men's rights guys they can't get
anything done so I'm like what the hell
and they all tell me that women are the
biggest swing voters so all the
politicians are catering to women
because
um basically like men are more loyal
even in parties
so we're where they'll like vote for
their party
um and just stick to it they're kind of
they're usually lifelong Republicans or
lifelong Democrats women we're just as
unloyal as we are in marriage it's like
they think they can buy us and we'll go
we're like oh they're giving us the
single and then single mothers
especially they're telling me is like
the biggest voting block so well is this
got to be about resources too right
don't you think that single women are
are looking for whoever's going to give
them the best economic pop and if they
someday get married they can yeah I
think they're just looking at who can
promise them the most resources and
that's it yeah no I know no but men you
know you'd think they could get benefits
too I guess not the single mother stuff
but you know well you know men are wired
differently so if you said to me Scott
what do these candidates will give you
more resources and I'll be like yes I
want those more resources but would be
five percent weaker on National Defense
than like whoa
that's five percent less on National
Defense I don't take that you can keep
your stuff I'll take the National
Defense so we have different priorities
yeah well
spend a lot of money so
[Laughter]
I'm not going to agree with you on that
it will haunt me forever why not it's
true
well I never can spend somebody too have
you ever heard a chick just say like
I've had enough spending I'm done this
is too much we're spending too much
money
I've never heard it like I'll have you
know I swear interviewing like 600 700
like young chicks completely changed my
view on chicks because they'll be like
we're on poverty and I'm like you have
fake nails I don't even have fake nails
like
I see the botox in your face like how
are you in poverty don't doesn't that
stuff go first no
yeah how much of that do you think is uh
it's 2023 and how much of it is gender
uh gender yeah okay yeah the the reason
I think it's gender is because women
just spend a lot more like I don't see
men spending money on clothes like that
appearance like they might spend money
on other stuff
but like when you I did a breakdown of
like what if a chick wanted like the
stuff you know women get nowadays it's
like nails
um a certain amount of clothes ever all
that stuff
it's expensive it adds up I can't tell
you off the top of my head I don't
really remember but
oh I could I can tell you what that
stuff costs yeah
that that stuff alone the the personal
maintenance
costs more than most people earn yeah
like actually more than most people who
earn all year yeah
I mean we make 80 percent of consumer
buying decisions think of that even
though we earn less like that's crazy
well now this gets me to one of my uh
pet peeves as someone who has an
economics background when we're talking
about who has the money and who makes
the money we always conveniently leave
out who spends it now if you had a
choice of making the money or spending
the money
and then making the money requires the
work and the spending money is you know
I guess the only work is the spending
which is a better deal oh yeah and like
you said yeah like
um one of the reasons I got married the
first time and the second time too I
guess is uh it's not the only reason but
was to give away my money
because I didn't have enough this is
literally true I had made enough money
and I looked around and I thought
well I like having just one shirt that I
wear for every one of my podcasts I
don't know if you know if you notice me
appearing on other podcasts always this
year
I don't really need a second shirt with
a collar I wear a t-shirt for my own
podcast
so I've got one car and I wish I had
zero I've got one house and I wish I
were renting because ownership of
anything is just a giant pain in the ass
so
I just thought wouldn't it be great to
combine my life with somebody who has
some actual spending needs and then the
money would be used in a productive way
instead of me buying a second car I
don't use so that was actually part of
my decision that part worked out really
well that's better than I could have
imagined meaning that's really easy to
spend money when you don't have money
yeah but when you bring money into a
situation where somebody hasn't had it
they have many ideas of how to spend it
uh more ideas than I have you know I
don't think of vacations and uh I could
have never understood how much the
maintenance program uh costs yeah the
the nails and lashes and stuff so those
are things that I don't have to deal
with and I never even think of so
bringing somebody in who could benefit
by the spending of the money
was actually part of the plan oh wow
that's so crazy our Network likes to
spend money just you know just you
but I'm like I've never heard a guy say
that he wanted to get married to spend
money
well what are you gonna do with your
money if you have money and you're
single and you're a guy what are you
gonna do with it
I mean most guys don't like one of one
of the 45 55k so well I don't know if
that's the average but yeah I mean
mostly cubicle people are over 100 I
think yeah but like is
yeah but that's counting servers and you
know the Baristas and stuff so but yes
yeah yeah once you get into a big office
building you're probably making more
than that what do you think you think's
gonna happen like in the next 50 years
with everything becoming so
technological well we're definitely
going to merge with the machines
I think the odds of sex lives becoming
you know fully digital is guaranteed
um so some number of people are just
going to be taken completely out of the
meeting mating cycle
and if the if the digital stuff
especially the virtual reality things I
don't know if you saw recent uh a recent
video with Lex Friedman Friedman and
Mark Zuckerberg using meta's new
technology that makes a photorealistic
version of you so you put on the goggles
and it looks like you're standing in
front of another person who's also
photorealistic and you could walk right
up to him and apparently if you get
close to them you actually feel like
you're close to a person
because it's so photorealistic so could
you get to the point where that plus um
you know a teledildonics or something
some uh some sex toys that work across
distance becomes your entire sexual
Outlet
because if you've got the Googles on and
part of your body is inserted or is with
a sex toy
are you gonna get oxytocin from that
because if you do it's pretty much the
end of humanity if you don't then it's
just sort of a digital experience that
can never match a human experience well
then we're still good but we're so close
and when I heard that it's creepy when
somebody gets close to you in the
digital world
that means you're responding to it like
a person
because you don't get creepy by anything
else that's close to you so makes me
wonder if they can if they can elicit
some dopamine and some oxytocin those
are the only currency that we work for
and you're not going to work for it in a
less economical way if you had to marry
somebody who might get sick and die and
cheat on you and spend your money versus
just putting on some headphones and you
get the same chemical kick
I really think that a lot of people just
be taken completely out of the
reproductive process
so that's what I think so you think
we're going to merge with machines and
that what percent of people do you think
would do that well if you look at Elon
musk's product uh neuro what is it
um I don't know how many people are
gonna put a chip in their skull but it
will depend entirely upon how much
benefits the first people get you know I
think you'll work with people who have
spine injuries first but if he gets past
that into recreational stuff
such as you're the same person but now
you have super powers because your brain
is more efficient and however many ways
it'll be hard to resist people with
money will get it so it'll start with
the stupid rich
and at some point it will become a civil
right
that everybody has a right to have a
chip in their head because it would be
such a superpower it would be unfair
that some people couldn't have them so I
think the government will make it
mandatory at some point or at least make
it free and then you think that'll be
the end of humanity in a sense because
we'll be cyborgs after that in other
words we'll be part machine part human
and we will be living extensive lives in
the non-real world in the digital realms
so whatever we are whatever you want to
call that it will be fundamentally
different than humans walking around in
the same space with each other is that
we
are that yeah how old are you in your uh
35 35
I'm 60. so it's interesting
um a Smartphone when I was like 13 maybe
so I kind of saw the beginning of like
the world changing you know because when
I was in high school
um it was like pictures like that was
the big thing everyone would like take a
picture at a get to you know but it's a
little it's a little different than like
now it's like you can't go anywhere
without being filmed like people are
always on their stories and all that
stuff so I've even seen it change and
it's a bit weird for me so I can't even
imagine someone in their 60s well
imagine imagine what I've seen I I was
before the smartphone but also before
personal computers
so imagine a childhood with no computer
and no smartphone people under 25 can't
even imagine that
um so I'm I'm one of the last crossover
um Generations you know the the
pre-smartphone and then smartphone so
I've I've lived them both and I feel
like that's going to confer some kind of
advantages but I'm not sure what but how
how is it to you like seeing the culture
change so much like how like what's that
been like you know the biggest thing is
I always assume that America would just
last forever because it it was always
some version of the same America for my
entire life until I'd say the last five
years we're now at a cost probably
because of Technology more than anything
of something that's big
but nobody knows what it is yet
so we're not the same people we were
even five years ago we understand that
the news is routinely fake it's not
sometimes wrong it's designed to be
wrong you know the the people who own
the news so to speak make sure it's
wrong it's a narrative it's not the news
maybe it's always been that way but
maybe we just found out because of
Technology
so there's a real fight for free speech
and maybe there always was yeah maybe we
were always just brainwashed kids and we
didn't know anything maybe the Pledge of
Allegiance and and all that was in the
movies they showed war in a positive
light we're pretty sure that was all
propaganda by today's you know measure
so the propaganda is much is stronger
and worse and more powerful and affects
more people now than maybe ever before
so it's we've sort of turned into a
full-time propaganda War it's a war for
mines I think maybe the biggest
difference is we went from controlling
people's bodies
you know forever into the way you
control their bodies is by controlling
their minds
so we always do both but I think it's
more about mind control going forward
and why do you think they do that like
fake the news do you think it's like the
government I think it's a combination of
uh government specifically one party
versus the other and sometimes it's our
intelligence agencies want to you know
control the minds of Americans for good
reasons usually sometimes bad I suppose
uh so it's a combination of people who
have similar interests in making sure
people don't see the raw truth and
um since there's money involved
it's tough to break that cycle because
you can't really start a the honest News
Channel with no money you know you have
to have a model that makes money and one
of the things we found is that what
makes the most money and gets the most
clicks are the things that make your
hair catch on fire
usually those are not true
so you know the Covington kid case where
the kid went up and was allegedly
yelling in the face of the Native
American guy and I saw that in my you
know immediately I was incense like oh
that kid right I hate that kid and then
you see a little bit more video and you
realize that the Native American guy was
the aggressor and the kid never did
anything but stand in one place and the
entire story was backwards So Stories
like that that get you like oh I'm so
angry are usually fake because the thing
that made you angry is something that
was so out of place that somebody did
something you shouldn't do in the wrong
place that's what gets you crazy ah how
could that person in that situation do
that thing and then you find out later
the reason it was so outrageous is that
it didn't happen
most of life is normal stuff so when you
see these incredible outrages it's
almost always incomplete in a context
certainly Meister recently then well
even wait so you said certainly what my
story is like that yeah all of my many
uh scandals over the years all of them
are just out of context that's all it is
yeah
there you had one you referred to black
people as a hate group right that's what
they're taking out of contact
yes
so here would you like to hear the
contest yeah yeah if you're okay I don't
I don't want you to like talk about
anything you don't want to talk about
but if oh no I have no restrictions okay
um so the first thing you need to know
is that I didn't make any comment about
anybody's genetic makeup
nothing about their chromosomes and
nothing about their culture they had
nothing to do with anything if if those
that had been part of the question then
racism would be a reasonable uh critique
but the background that's left out of
all the reporting is that the reason I
said that first of all is hyperbole so
you know just assume there's some
hyperbole in there it wasn't intended to
be an accurate statement
so the hyperbole was because we're in a
situation where we have ESG and CRT and
Dei if your audience is not familiar
with all those those are things which at
least in America and some other places
as well uh have in common that there's a
victim class usually we're talking about
Black Americans if it's here and that
there's an oppressor class usually
thought of as the rich white guys of
which I'm a member
so if you're in a place where the
dominant social training is that one
group have been oppressed there's one
group that is oppressing them still you
know not just in the past but right now
and that oppressing group has the stuff
that belongs to you because that's what
that that's what everybody's being
trained to believe in that situation
uh you would expect that they would have
some
animosity toward their oppressors
wouldn't that be normal yeah that would
be the most normal thing
so why would you stay around if you had
been lumped in the oppressor class why
would you stay around you're you're in a
dangerous situation because you're
surrounded by people who believe that
you have their stuff and they have a
moral right to get it back
you need to get out of there so the the
hate group thing was just hyperbole it
was based on erasmussen poll which
wasn't important to the larger point the
larger point is
forget about anybody's you know DNA or
even their color if one group has been
weaponized against the other
you should get out of that group if
you're the group that has been targeted
as the uh the bad guys
now now let me extend that you may have
seen in the news that governor hokel of
New York and also ex-president Bill
Clinton have both said that they think
that the uh the Asylum City thing that
the
um that the cities are doing like New
York City are a mistake and should be
rolled back
now why are they saying that it's not
because they think that the immigrants
coming into New York City have bad DNA
they're not saying it for that they
don't think they have bad chromosomes
they don't think they have bad character
they don't think that they're bad
culture
they're simply saying that if you take
the existing system that is New York
City
and you inject a bunch of people in it
of the uh that don't have jobs let's say
that it creates disruption that's going
to be bad for New York City and it's not
especially helping the people you
brought in because there's probably a
better way to handle it
in effect they're saying these people
are fine
but because of the situation you've
created we don't want them on the same
block as us
basically saying you know get these
communal out of here that's essentially
what they're saying now they're good
people or at least in terms of you know
these statements they're they're saying
kind things they want the people to do
well they're not criticizing the
immigrants or whatsoever they're not
criticizing the residents of New York
City who feel this burden they're simply
saying you've created a system that
doesn't work well together and that's
what I say about Dei and ESG and c and
CRT it's a it's a set of systems
which poisoned the the relationships
between the races and makes it an
incentive for one to avoid the other if
they can there's no real way to do that
but that's the incentive that's being
created oh no that happened to me oh my
gosh it was like I had um a co-host so
it was so crazy for like a year I
thought we were Pals one day he just
comes up makes a video saying I'm a
colonizer I'm like a colonizer
I was like wait what what no it's not
actually I have like first-hand
experience with that I thought we were
good I was like we were like PALS like a
week ago and even the title of the video
was like the truth about Pearl right and
when I saw it was scheduled I thought he
was going to swear I was on the phone
with my dad I was like he's gonna say
nice things he's like I don't think so
and I saw it and I was just like wait
what like I was like all right all right
now take take your example
um I would without knowing I would
assume that you you know you're not
thinking there's anything wrong with
this individual's DNA
right oh no no
no I thought we were friends and
wouldn't you say there's there's nothing
wrong with this culture that has
anything to do with this right because
the culture understand that but is it
true
that he if he had not been your co-host
you would not have had that problem
right and it's not because of the
personality it's because the personality
has been infected by the same social
forces that are infecting us all so if
you look at the social forces as the bad
part then you can give all the people a
break which is the way I prefer to do it
yeah and I also say that if you want
real diversity we were moving in the
right direction actually because we used
to say everything's black or white it's
black people and then there's white
people and then we move to
intersectionality
so oh don't just say I'm a black person
because I might also be disabled I might
also be lgbtq and that's going to be
different and that instinct is right
because that is a different situation
but I think we need to keep going
and realize that people are infinitely
different even within their within their
culture in their group
so if we can treat people as individuals
then it's easy to solve problems because
I can look at an individual and say oh
what do you need oh you need this advice
or you need this contact you need this
job I know how to fix a person I don't
know how to fix fix the difference
between an average where there's no
average black person then there's no
average white person that's not a
problem I'm willing to work on because
averages don't exist well the average
people don't exist but I'm willing
definitely willing to work on what would
help individuals you said average people
don't exist yeah there's no such thing
as an average black person
but yet yet we're told to compare the
average white person to the average
black person and neither of those people
exist
it's purely imaginary
there's no one solution that all black
people need or that all white people
need everybody's got their own little
situation if I were to randomly you know
throw a dart and somebody didn't
complain that I threw a dart at him
um you would find somebody who's whose
biggest problem in life is unlikely to
be systemic racist
it's going to be well if I had this job
skill
I would have that job yeah it's usually
something pretty simple yeah well it
would have helped this guy because I was
like well you would have because his
whole thing was like I didn't pay him
enough and I was like well if you were
better I would have paid you more I was
like you see you saw the guy that was
over he makes good money like I was like
I'm like just because it was you you
know you know then I'm the bad guy it's
like I don't know the way I would have
played it would would be to ask for a
raise that's just me that's how I would
have played that situation yeah well
would
like a network
and I just said look we don't have a ton
of cash right now come back in six
months and then he didn't like that he
wanted it and then it was the truth
about Pearl I was like I couldn't
believe it
[Laughter]
but you you also said you CL you lost
multiple job opportunities for being
white yeah my first big job was at a
bank Crocker Bank in San Francisco and
when I tell this story
a lot of people say this can't be true
there's no way this is true and it is
well this is 100 true my boss called me
in her office one day and she said the
word has come down from Senior
Management that we're getting in trouble
because we don't have diversity in
Senior Management
and the only way we'll ever get there is
to stop promoting white men
and so she said until further notice you
know you're not promotable
and I said what like I don't even
believe it but it doesn't it didn't
sound like something something to say
directly to you yeah I was like I'm
surprised they told you this like they
could have at least lied like you know
what I mean so so I did the rational
thing that one does the free market I I
quit
so I went to work with the phone company
and got on their Management program and
I was finishing my MBA at a good school
and it looked like I was you know
destined for Senior Management and one
day my boss called me in his office and
he said I don't know how to tell you
this but the word has come down
that uh we don't have enough diversity
and until further notice we can never
promote you
and that's when I quit working hard at
the phone company and said I guess I'll
have to work for myself
so I tried a few things one of the
things I tried was the Dilbert comic and
then when that took off
um you know I stayed working in my day
job for a number of years
to get material mostly and then I I left
and Dilbert took off and there was an
animated Dilbert TV show for two F
seasons on UPN after the first season it
got picked up so that meant it was doing
well and but it had been running on a
Monday night and UPN decided that they
wanted to turn Monday into a block of uh
only African-American comedies
so since Dilbert didn't fit that I got
moved to a different time slot
anybody who knows about how television
Works knows that at least in the old
days when your time slot moved usually
we're dead and there's a long history of
shows that were successful until the
time slot moved it's a thing so it moved
and then their ratings collapsed and it
got canceled uh and then my more current
career as a Cartoonist and writer I was
uh completely canceled for saying
something that any black person could
have said that
but because it came from me and all the
context was stripped out of it and then
I got canceled for that but certainly
that was only because I'm white and male
I don't think I would have been canceled
in fact only Democrats canceled me
there's no Republican who thought I
should be canceled I've never met one
are there like Solutions moving forward
so like we don't have the end of
humanity and have a crazy like race war
you know so you want the optimistic yeah
can I can I have can I could I have an
optimistic and a pessimistic I'd like to
hear optimistic first because this job
has made me a bit of a pessimist and I'm
trying to turn it around all right so
the first thing you need to know is that
the media is now fully designed to show
you all the bad news right so it's
nothing but bad news because that's what
we click on and like to argue about so
you're seeing a totally misleading
picture of how bad things are now there
might be some things that are even worse
you know but mostly things are not
nearly as bad as they look uh the next
thing is what I call the Adam's law of
slow-moving disasters
and the way that works is that Humanity
has been terrific in fact we have a
hundred percent uh record of solving uh
cataclysmic you know population ending
problems so we we didn't overpopulate
and run out of food we figured out how
to make more food
we didn't run out of fuel in the 70s or
oil we figured out how to frack and find
more oil
we did not have a year 2000 bug because
we had plenty of time to get ready for
it and so we just reprogrammed it move
slime
and the even the uh the ozone hole the
hole in the ozone we actually fix that
there was no hole in the ozone no way I
don't believe it well that's what we
were told
well
so so either we solved it or we stopped
talking about one of those two things
happen
who knows but so and and you could you
could keep going with just you know
dozens of examples it's only the things
that catch us off guard that we're in
trouble like the pandemic you know we
maybe some experts were a little bit
prepared but basically the public wasn't
so that that kicked their ass
but if you look at all of our problems
from you know climate change to
you know even the falling population to
the Ukraine war
will probably make all of that work
you know one way or another humans are
amazing at making things work the other
thing I'll say is that because of social
media we have far more exposure to
stupid people than ever before so it
looks like everything's getting stupider
because you just have all these stupid
people coming at you on social media all
day long whereas before you have to be
kind of talented to even be on let's say
to be Walter Cronkite to be on the news
you have to be one of the more talented
people now that's not the case so you're
seeing this misleading
misleading incompetence but at the same
time there is a pretty big incompetence
problem in the country we have a massive
incompetence aren't IQs dropping like
pretty bad uh the the people make a
difference are a very few number of
people right there's only a few Steve
Jobs and even within Apple it was
probably you know a dozen or so
Engineers who did all the important
stuff to make it apple and then it could
be self-sustaining so the people really
change things
there aren't that many of them and it
wouldn't matter if 80 of the world got
number
maybe you'd hardly notice you know maybe
the robots when an AI will pick up some
of the slack but the people who really
change things are born that way I think
I mean I think Steve Jobs was just born
to change things you know Elon Musk was
just born to change things and I think
that no matter how badly you know the
the lowest 80 percent of the public is
doing the top 20 is still killing it
um recently I spent some time with
uh father and a daughter who
was one of these kids that makes you
makes you have confidence in the future
I don't know if you've had that
experience but you you could meet 10
kids in a row and you say oh man we are
screwed we are so screwed like you
turned on Tick Tock for five minutes and
you're like oh God oh God this is what's
going to be running the world I know
I say that to my little sister sometimes
but but try this experiment spend an
hour with a a kid
who's one of the ones who's going to
make a difference you can see it right
away right they're just powerful and
they are more powerful than ever
so so the ones that are going to make a
difference are more high-powered more
powerful smarter more capable even
healthier than ever before in history
the bottom 80 percent May in fact be
trending in the wrong direction because
the school system is totally broken
or maybe the reason that you mentioned
but I think has more to do with the
teachers units who are
stop it
I didn't even say it I tried to stay out
of trouble
I've been canceled enough what do you I
mean I I don't say anything that
controversial just women are responsible
for all problems in society
no controversy there at all no no
certainly certainly the school system is
completely broken and I I say that's the
biggest source of systemic racism oh
yeah that was a poor black kid going to
get ahead if he doesn't have school and
we don't really have school you know at
the at the the poorer locations it's
basically like it doesn't exist you're
you're getting zero people who can do
math that's like having no school at all
you know I don't even know all my
multiplication tables I swear I swear
you know and you know people my mom says
I shouldn't tell people this but I just
I'm just an honest person
but I I have to dive into that for a bit
I don't
there there are probably that means
there are only some multiple some
multiplication
you know processes that you don't know
like I have trouble with the sevens
unless I can't do sevens either that's
like the sevens and the and the eights
those are the two I also can't and I
can't visualize like certain
kilograms or whatever like there's
certain like they told me I wouldn't I
don't remember what grade it was but
they're like if you don't memorize this
you won't pass uh look where I am now
baby it's like I still don't know it
yeah I I used I used to think I would
write a book
about all the things that I don't know
how to do that people would assume that
I do because my whole day is being
presented with something I should fix
but I don't know how so I just don't do
it
so there would be sometimes years that I
would log onto my computer and some
message would come up before I could do
my work
and I would say to myself
I don't know how to make that go away
like is something unimportant
so I'll just leave it there for two
years
I'll be like well I wish I knew how to
make that go away
and so everything from my you know my
car to my you know just everything there
are all these things I don't know how to
do but they're small so I could just
sort of put them off
yeah but it's an enormous body of things
I don't know how to do at this point
yeah I mean if you remember this mic
stuff I don't know how to set this up
so okay so you think that the smarter
people will keep getting smarter and fix
all our problems optimistically well in
terms of engineering and inventing stuff
and being leaders yes I do okay so what
about what's your like pessimistic that
it's all over well the pessimistic
version is that there's something in
society that's falling apart
and I don't know if we can figure out
what it is
um it feels like it's something about
the media maybe it's that there are too
many brainwashers working at once
I often feel like we're having a uh like
the world there's a movie called
underworld in which the ideas that the
uh the werewolves and the vampires have
been having a you know hundreds of years
battle that the humans just don't notice
but it's like this big battle going on
so sometimes I think the real world is
that below the surface are there the
real movers and shakers and persuaders
are in this pitched battle
that the people above the surface hardly
ever see anything except oh there's a
new law like they'll see the end product
of something but they don't see the
battle so that's the way I see the world
and I suppose
and yeah the werewolves could win or the
vampires could win and we would end up
in a World War II Holocaust situation
again
and I would not have imagined any of
that was possible until the January 6
sentences started coming down
and it looks like we live in a country
in which
um political dissent
is being criminalized
and you know yes yes I know they
committed some crimes Etc but we don't
no I don't think anybody thinks they
were treated the way people would
normally be treated in similar
situations how did we look at Trump and
that looks completely political so if we
reach a point where people are obviously
going to jail for political stuff
and people are obviously being canceled
for having political voices I think the
best way to understand my situation is
that um
um in my own opinion
probably a top 20 Persuader in politics
now most people would not know that
you'd have to really be following
politics to now my little role
but
um that's not a coincidence that I got
taken off the chessboard at before an
election so you're seeing one by one all
of the strongest the best communicators
are all being targeted what do you mean
taking off the chessboard like canceled
cancel meeting our voices are being
reduced so for example canceling Tucker
Carlson one of the best communicators
should have silenced him he went to
Twitter where his audience got bigger
but it's still only people on Twitter
so he has actually been marginalized
even though he has a bigger audience on
Twitter
um if you look at Russell Brand
you know regardless of what anybody did
or actually did I don't know who's
guilty or not guilty of anything but I
don't believe he would have been
targeted except that his voice was
politically persuasive and he's a good
communicator
I'm in that category too where
um for last several years you know there
have been a number of hit jobs and
attempts to cancel me this is just the
one that's stuck and it came out I think
the Washington Post was probably the
leader on this and that's political by
its nature oh you you mean the the stuff
we talked about earlier yeah the
cancellation my cancellation is probably
more related to my political opinions
than it is to anything I said that got
me canceled so you talked about January
6th and that was I I don't know too much
about January 6 but they they like
stormed the capital was that it yeah
that was it I don't you see
there is a part a point in my life where
I just wasn't paying attention to
anything political like oh yeah anyways
but you know I didn't pay attention to
January 6 when it happened either I just
didn't think it was important at the
time yeah and so I don't really unders
like they weren't supposed how'd they
get in well that's part of the mystery I
mean they they broke him but there's
also reports of doors being opened for
them for on the inside
so the conspiracy people say there's
people on the inside that wanted this to
look bad so they opened the doors and
they also say there were people in the
crowd who were really feds and they were
whipping up the crowd to do more than
maybe they would have done on their own
so I don't know about any of that
um I do know that it's being you know
called an insurrection
like the idea is that you can conquer a
superpower if you trespass enough in one
building
and I believe that the idea is that they
would have gotten control of the the
nuclear Triad and our entire military by
wandering around taking selfies in the
capital
so that's what the Democrats have sold
to the country that we were in Mortal
danger of losing the country because
people wandered around now let me take
their side for a second but Scott but
Scott there was real violence there yes
there was Buzz Scott some of them had
some like weapons and clubs and stuff
yes I did but they were hurting people
real violence yes there was it's
something did someone get hurt
yeah so the people got hurt got clubbed
pretty badly so so I'm not minimizing
the uh the damage it was pretty bad
but it was also a very small number of
people and a hundred percent of the
public says they should pay for their
crimes Republicans say it Democrats say
it so there's no no debate on that
but how exactly were they going to
conquer the country
suppose they had taken the hostages
you know suppose they had held pets
were we going to surrender the military
what what exactly was the sequence of
events that would make this a proper
Insurrection there was no path that
anybody could have ever seen that would
cause the Insurrection people to own the
country and suppose that they had
succeeded in delaying the process
and gotten some alternate electors
involved
what would happen next
would Trump just take the presidency and
everybody would say well that's fine
with us or would it go immediately to
the Supreme Court because January 6 you
know wasn't the date the new president
takes over that was still you know weeks
away
Supreme Court could have said uh yeah we
agree that these alternate electors make
sense or they could say that they don't
and then we would have had the
legitimate legal process
um instead the Democrats have said that
the Republicans real intention was not
to delay and just recount the votes
which is what they all said but secretly
they wanted to take over the country and
install Trump in a non-legal way
now I've never met a republican who
wanted to violate the constitution
never
and so the claim that they would have
let's say if the Supreme Court had said
no this doesn't work it's
unconstitutional
Republicans would have said we hate that
but okay that would have been the end of
it so did they get a long sentence uh
they got crazy long sentences for the
crimes that we're aware of yeah now some
of some of the ones deserve long
sentences they did some bad stuff but
there were a lot of people who were
simply just there and the door was open
everybody walked through
and they probably thought they were not
committing a crime they just thought
they were protesting and it was a
vigorous protest and they happened to be
on the inside and sometimes on the
outside and so I don't even I doubt they
processed it as a crime in their minds
do you think that the election was
stolen uh I'll tell you what I know
um every system in America
that could be corrupted and there was a
lot of money at stake
and it was really complicated that's a
big complicated system
every one of those we know to be corrupt
so we know the doj the FBI we know
Congress is corrupt we're pretty sure
the Biden family was corrupt we're
pretty sure that everything in our
health care situation was corrupt the
big Pharma is corrupt the you know the
industrial military complex corrupt we
know those are all corrupt and in the
last few years we've gotten absolute
confirmation
however
luckily there are 50 separate elections
in each state and then all of the
precincts which operated perfectly
that's the story we've been told
that everything's broken except all 50
states and all of the precincts within
the states working perfectly
now
I don't know if that's true or not
because I have no direct information
that would say the election was stolen
what I do know and I can say this with
complete confidence
if the elections have never been rigged
in the past
they're guaranteed to be rigged in the
future because we have a system that
guarantees it maybe people have tried
and failed maybe they couldn't figure it
out but as long as the process is
non-transparent meaning that even if you
do an audit and a recount you're kind of
counting the stuff you already counted
you don't know if nothing ever reached
you in the first place you don't know if
electronically anything's happening in
the county machines
so if you can't look at all the details
and there there's big stakes and every
other system that had big stakes and
lots of people and it's complicated
where you could hide all your Mischief
in the complications those are all
corrupt every one of them
so it's only about at a time so we don't
know if the election system is corrupt
we only know that it has to be in the
long run whether it happened already
I don't know but I want to add this
if you believe the Hitler
was running for election and you already
knew he was a seller so you're not
you're not speculating that in the
future he'll become Hitler you believe
he's already Helen
and he's running for election and you're
in charge of the elections and you have
the ability to throw the election if you
and and get away with it
would you throw the election to prevent
Hitler from coming to office I asked
that question on the x-platform in a
little poll
two-thirds of the people who answered
said they would not have rigged an
election to stop Hitler
all of them are aligned because they all
they all would have they they tried to I
think I think I voted no in that poll
but well if you voted poll if you voted
no it's because you added an assumption
that wasn't there such as you can't be
sure he'll be Hillary right you probably
had some reason but what was your reason
for saying no why wouldn't you stop
Hillary
um well it was because it's like you
can't rig an election
you know like
what
like you're just not hold on let me make
it even more Stark
you have a chance to strangle baby
Heller
but in this weird example you know that
I can't kill a baby
to stop the Holocaust well I mean you
could find a woman that will though I
mean we kill our own kids like there's
no tomorrow you know what I mean it's
like but you you wouldn't strangle a
baby to stop the Holocaust no I can't
it's a baby
will you call me if this happens
if you ever get in this situation call
me I'll be right there I will strangle
that baby right in front of you
oh okay the difference between men and
women I guess
no
I know this is women should be this is
why women should be banned from the
military really truly and I don't think
women should be able to like hold
political office either that's a tough
sell what's the argument for that oh I
just think every time like we're too
emotional our emotions just get in the
way they took Queens from the last 500
years right they actually are more
likely to wage war I don't think women
understand violence the way that men
understand violence so I'll give you an
example if you start acting up in a bar
you know somebody could beat your ass
you know what I mean yeah yeah right
yeah women I just don't think and I
think it's very clear we don't
understand it right you you see us go
like I'll see women beating up a bigger
man like like so much bigger and if he
hits back up boohoo she's support poor
poor anyways
um but so my my thought process is one
women can't like deal with the
consequences the same way men do and
when women get into Power if you look at
like the first like top 10 women or
shortest terms it's all these women that
quit I just noticed women kind of just
suck with power like I like seriously I
couldn't think of like one time women
were good with power it's like in the
last hundred years we got power in the
legal system what do we do screw them in
I love Margaret Thatcher now I don't
know much about Margaret Thatcher I hear
I've heard about her I don't know much
about it
no okay are there exceptions
sure we could we could say like I'm sure
Ivanka Trump is like great you know I'm
sure I don't really know much about her
but I'm just assuming like if you're
raised by Trump who I would say is a
good president that there's going to be
exceptions of women but it's like for
every one exception I find like 10 women
that suck you know and so it's like is
it really worth it is it really well
so here we get back to my infinite
difference
philosophy okay since there are there
there's no average woman
so therefore you have to deal with
everybody as an individual and you
wouldn't want to have turned away
Margaret Thatcher if she came in for it
no I would have I think a guy could have
did it better probably I'm sure there's
some guy that could have did just as
good
well you can say that about everything
there's always somebody who could have
done it better that's a universal truth
yeah so I'm like what's it like at what
cost is my question it's like women
voting at what cost
women in office and then like they
always do the same thing they go sleep
with someone in the politics like they
just become hoarse it's so crazy like
I'll give you an example like that one
Republican chick who like she just left
her Hut and you could say why she left
whatever but it's still the same guy so
whatever he was doing now he was doing
10 years ago
out of the chick in the movie theater I
don't I don't know these people I just I
just noticed that yeah Lauren uh buber
and I don't I don't really care do you
know what I mean it's not my my deal I'm
not like you know but my I just I just
noticed something women we get into
these positions of power and we just
start sleeping with everybody I don't
know what it is
Kamala Harris like if the vice president
did this what your your normal
congresswoman well I can answer your
question why they started sleeping with
everybody when they get power well yeah
because they're around all the powerful
men we love that
yeah
obviously do you know what I mean but
I'm like we're a little different like
we can be all influenced and like like
it's like a girl we'll never have gone
to church in her life right then she
dates this like Catholic or Christian
guy now she's in church every week you
want men are a little bit more loyal and
their political party and like to their
friends like I just you know are there
exceptional women maybe like one
I'm just
but I just think by and large and then
like you know when the exceptions happen
here's the thing like okay now imagine
this we're in this Society they say no
women in office you guys have been too
much of you just give away all
this money and you do all this stuff
right and so we say and all the guys get
together and say we got to be done with
it and they say okay okay now there's a
Margaret Thatcher that comes along right
and she's like amazing maybe she was
raised by like a king or a ruler because
I just imagine I don't know much about
Thatcher but I'm just imagining this
woman was raped because usually they're
raised by a really good guy and that's
how they become so amazing it's like a
really smart Dad it's like a daddy's
girl this is just my guess now as I
could be completely off but so my
thought is all the guy like when there
is an exception it's different than the
rule do you know what I mean like
they'll let her in but they're like just
this one because she's proven to be so
good that she can go in you know but we
know the rule is get these chicks out of
here
I don't know if that's the rule don't
you don't you think in modern politics
they they want more women in power I
mean they might I want less
I'm a sexist so I'm like and because I
think to myself and you know I'm in I
play sports I've played Sports my whole
life and these are I would argue the
most like rational more then you get the
crazy lesbians but there's a group of
women in sports I'll say that they're
usually like hard workers pretty
rational whatever and I'm like no
they're still like emotional it's like
once a week or once a month they get we
get our periods like so we're all crazy
for a month and you want you want them
with the nuke button a woman on her
period no
no I can't do that
I was just I was just the other I think
yesterday I was watching your you've got
a viral clip
in which you're uh asking women if they
think they should be leaders and and
you're asking what what about on your
period and then you're asking the women
if they've ever acted differently when
they were on their period and they
insist that they are not and then you
ask the next question which was
diabolical which is have any of your
partners ever noticed like
well because I
because I go through life on like la la
mode where nobody tells us anything
we're just like these pretty you know
and they're like ah she's pretty
whatever and
what I realized is like yeah like most
of the men don't really complain they're
kind of content with life and so you
know half of us chicks have no idea how
annoying we are to the men we have no
idea you know it's making uh sort of
analogy that I like to make between big
dogs and little dogs have you ever
noticed that big dogs
big dogs tend to be they'll they'll do
whatever you want be like hey big dog
sit down it'll be like
[Laughter]
but if you have a little yappy dog like
I do you'd be like all right dog sit
down they're like yeah no sit sit
they can't be controlled and and I've
always wondered like why is it so
obvious that the big ones are well
behaved and little ones are not and then
I thought about it is selective
breathing
if you were a big dog and you didn't do
what you were told they just killed you
so you didn't have any more little dogs
and if you're a little dog that didn't
do what you were told you just thought
it was funny I was fighting
let's have some more of these get some
more ankle biters
so you're saying it could be the same
situation women are dogs I'm gonna use
that that's gonna be my next one
not our big dogs no no but to your point
men can't get away with the same things
that women can get away with so it's
just incentive yeah but I think I really
think like women when we get power we
just kind of suck I don't know what it
is like we just I just have no evidence
that women do the right thing with power
none so okay imagine this they said you
can be anything right to women they said
you can do anything and we're picking
only fans this is so crazy they said you
can literally do anything ladies go
crazy four percent and I know they say a
lie about the stud I did not lie you
just can you include cam models and only
fans workers four percent of women four
percent that's more than teachers Dr
David Baker yeah four percent of women
are I'm sorry under 35 your age group's
a little different over 35 is different
under 35 are on only fans are due camera
that does not include that that's
because that's what they would do they
would be like oh Pearl you're
selectively getting these chicks on your
show you just pick them you cherry pick
why don't you find the good women
they're in church and I'm like good luck
like
and I'm like you can't it's like how not
to get an only Fan's chick like I'm not
even like because if you include okay
that's four percent that means there's
more only fans were workers than
teachers this doesn't include the women
that do that are prostitutes that do
um low-level sex work on Instagram I
would guess it's like 10 this is crazy
then we think about it then we think
about in court right we go to court
we're like are we going to be nice to
the men and not steal their money oh we
steal it they're like okay are you gonna
stay with your husband or divorce him we
just divorce him you know and so I'm
like what evidence and then we get power
and politics and what do we do we choose
violence War like more likely than men
which intimate partner violence 70
female uh were the most likely ones to
kill the babies the kids before and
after birth so it's like what evidence
do I have that women do the right thing
ever well
are men killing it
why so yeah I would argue that nobody's
good at being a leader it's almost
non-existent some Get Lucky
you this is sort of the Dilbert take on
it because as some people are in office
when lucky things happen and some people
are in office when unlucky things happen
if there had not been a pandemic
would there have been a second uh the
second term of trump I mean it's usually
external things and we want the Ukraine
war be one of the big things that
determines who the next leader is and
how that goes will determine the legacy
of that leader there's a lot of luck
involved is what I'm saying and we don't
have a lot of leaders who are just
crushing it well they all look like
they're bumbling through and some are
getting lucky well I'll tell you what
okay I'll tell you this is my theory to
this okay the men like make each other
better leaders can't imagine okay
imagine you throw like 50 men on an
island they'll just bully each other out
of being annoying they'll like they'll
kind of get a little stronger and better
like I really think when men get
together they they become I mean don't
get me wrong they'll be more crafts
there's like locker room talk whatever
the women just like get worse you know
they just become worse like men it's
like they naturally put themselves in a
hierarchy that makes sense women just is
like everyone's amazing and special and
awesome imagine that now like that's our
default for whatever reason imagine that
in charge of a country well here we are
because all the politicians are catering
to us women well okay that's a lot um I
I would add to that one of the things
that women are always surprised at is
the amount of violence that men carry
with them in their minds all the time oh
yeah all through
and it's because we're the ones who have
to stop the violence if it comes in the
room right if you and if you and I are
sitting in the same room I'm checking
the exits and the windows I'm looking at
what blunt objects I have to defend
myself against the the Intruder and
you're probably thinking something like
well as soon as these guys start
fighting I'm going to get out that door
yeah and like how quickly can I do a
light job you know what I mean uh but I
I think that having uh violence as your
default that even if you don't do any
you're always you're always ready for it
probably is a good skill for leadership
because leadership is implied violence
all the time you know follow these rules
or people with guns will put you in jail
you know or your country is going to be
invaded at any minute so it's all
violence so the the proper management of
your violence might come more naturally
to people who think violently from the
moment they wake up to the time they go
to sleep that's possible yeah so what
I'm hearing is you're with me you get
these checks out of office
I believe
there could be some really good female I
think Nikki Haley could be a perfectly
good leader if you liked your policies
yeah policies or separate conversation
but she seems like a very capable person
you don't think she can do a good job
Nikki you don't think she could do as
well as Chris Christie as president I
don't know who Chris Christie is I'm not
as I'm more cultural than political he's
not breaking through all right
let's say do you think she would do a
worse job than Mike Pence as president
no I'd pick Pence would you yeah just
because yes okay you're consistent at
least you're consistent I I would pick
Nikki Haley over a bench even though I
liked him as a vice president he was a
good vice president no I'd take him but
usually okay I'll tell you I feel like
the leaders we don't want are the ones
that are more like what women so name
one give me give me an example like Jeb
Bush he's kind of you know I just think
you know he's less like masculine when
you think of him than like like
yeah yeah
was he masculine or feminine I mean
don't they think he's like uh isn't
there like a whole I mean I I don't I
don't know but you I mean you know but
no I think I think the gender preference
question the rumors that is yeah or
irrelevant to whether he gives off a
male or female vibe I'd say you kind of
like when he gives his speeches he's
more like womanly I don't know you don't
see it you don't see it
well he's also got that deep voice
he does manly things well except when he
rides his bicycle but uh at least he
plays basketball but I think of a guy's
guy I think of Putin I don't know why
he's coming to my head I just see him on
a horse
[Laughter]
you know there
is no biography or autobiography I'd
rather read than an honest one about
Putin like wouldn't you like to know how
his actual life is like the real life
what he's done work
like what does he do after work would
you be interested in that because it's
not what we do whatever we call what
he's doing no poo in like
like so horrible
horrible but I keep accidentally
covering like Russia bans this and I'm
just like based I'm like do I kind of
like Putin
because I think he banned like I don't
know what it was but it was something
that I agree was it only fans or
something well I know he doesn't like
wokeness in general yeah so he may be
right about that but I think I have to
say I have to say something bad about
Putin now
um this is for the people who will be
watching this later to make hit pieces
on me I am against Putin I do not like
him
okay okay I don't everyone I don't
really know much about him everyone
growing up just said he was bad but I
just see a couple policies that I'm like
oh okay do I have to say that well no
nobody says he's incompetent you know
everybody says he's apparently a good
operator he knows how to get the job
done whatever the job is but uh he might
be a little bit evil a little bit evil I
don't know much about him
I hope I didn't let you down oh no I had
a great time all right good
um well can you tell the people where
they can find you well you can find me
at
scottadams.locals.com if you want to
subscribe to my political and also the
Dilbert comic and other comics and
uh or you could buy my book reframe your
brain available wherever you get books
Amazon's your best bet and uh that's a
good start and on the X platform at
Scott Adams says yeah I just I just just
bought your book I haven't read it yet
though
but change your life I'm excited that's
so that's why I bought it you said like
easy to read I'm like yes
you'll never be the same okay guys
um make sure you like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel also if
you want to get your women shouldn't
vote t-shirt you know I I know Scott's
over here saying women should be in
office don't listen to him women
shouldn't even be voting
get your um T-shirt today the Link's in
the description and in the comments
section we're shipping soon so like the
video subscribe and I'll talk to you
next time
[Music]